mientras el commit 19 sigue causando
estragos en el mundo en la ciudad china
de wuhan en el virus ha dado para una
exposición o más bien un tributo
positivo a la respuesta de las
autoridades sobre la epidemia
son inches el pueblo y la vida del
pueblo es lo que más cuenta es promesa
del partido chino acoger y curarnos a
todos es lo que más hemos hecho para
vencer al virus
uno de los símbolos de ello es el
hospital juego se han construido en 10
días para controlar y aislar a los
pacientes más graves
pero tras la construcción ultra rápida
del hospital que está a mis espaldas hay
una verdad el sistema de salud no estaba
preparado para enfrentar tal flujo de
contagiados
la lentitud administrativa los pocos
efectivos y la falta de financiación
catapultaron la expansión del virus de
media hacían falta 23 días entre la
aparición de los síntomas y el
diagnóstico final
franklin algunos intentaron documentar
estas dificultades y pagaron el precio
es el caso de ciudadanos periodistas
como fan bing arrestado el 9 de febrero
desde entonces su amigo sanguino ha
sabido de él inspirado por fannie por el
médico lingual liang fallecido por el
virus y que intentó alertar de la
enfermedad considera que la libertad de
expresión habría podido salvar vidas
y es como digo el día dijo antes de
fallecer una sociedad saludable no puede
hablar con una sola voz si las
autoridades hubieran permitido otras
voces y críticas y hubieran sido
transparentes sin detener a periodistas
ciudadanos seguro que habrían habido
menos muertes que las de hoy
oficialmente el kobe 19 ha causado la
muerte a tres mil 868 personas en wuhan
cifra que en china es mejor no
cuestionar